Hi everyone.
My name is Trudy mechanic and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to today's talks
at Google event featuring
bestselling author,
educator and consultant Rachel Simmons.
Um,
as the mother of an 11 year old girl.
I've been a big fan of Rachel's for a
few years now and I've found her work in
valuable as I've worked to understand
and help my daughter navigate the
challenges of growing up today. And let
me tell you there are more than a few. Um,
I've also been a little bit surprised
to find that Rachel's lessons and
teachings have been so relevant
to my own life because shocker,
it turns out the challenges that girls
face don't just stop at the end of
adolescence. Um, so really happy.
Rachel's here to join us today.
A bit more about Rachel.
She is the New York Times best selling
author of the books odd girl out and the
curse of the good girl.
Her most recent book,
which she'll be talking about with us
today is enough as she is how to help
girls move beyond impossible
standards of success to live healthy,
happy, and fulfilling lives. Pretty cool.
Rachel is also an educator.
She consults nationally on women's
professional development and is a national
spokesperson for the always like a girl
and keds brave life project campaigns.
She was the host of the PBS television
special a girl's life and her writing has
appeared in the Washington Post
Atlantic sleet and the New York Times.
Rachel is a regular contributor to good
morning America and appears often in the
national media.
Odd girl out was adapted into a highly
acclaimed lifetime television movie.
Rachel cofounded,
the national nonprofit girls leadership
and that's actually very important and
important as an organization because
what it does is it takes the research and
work that she's done and puts it
into actual practical application.
We're lucky that Simone who cofounded
girls leadership and as the executive
director is here with us today and
we'll have the opportunity to learn more
about that amazing organization as well.
At the end of Rachel's Talk we
will have some time for Q and a.
For those of you on live stream,
there is a dory available.
It is go slash Rachel Simmons Dash Story.
And for those of you
who have books in hand,
Rachel has kindly offered to stick around
after the talk at the back of the room
to sign them. With that, please
join me in welcoming Rachel Simmons.
Thanks Trudy. Thank you. Um, hello.
It is a pleasure to be with you today.
I want to thank Google and Google talks
and Trudy Mckenna for putting this
together.
Um,
so I want to talk with you
both as potential parents
in the audience but also as
individuals because as Trudy said,
there's no question that a lot of what
I write about not only applies to girls
but applies to grownups,
applies to boys and men. And um,
I have had that pointed out to me many,
many times over the last four weeks.
I've been touring this book
all over the country. Um,
today is actually the last day of my
tour, so woo hoo. And, um, and so, yeah.
So I really, um, and if I'm honest,
so much of what I write about come from
comes from personal challenges that I
myself have been navigating and trying
to make peace with. And so with that,
I encourage you to listen with
lots of different hats. Um,
today what I'd like to explore with you
in the 30 minutes or so that I have to
talk with you are three
things. One is, uh,
to talk about ways that the culture has
changed for girls since we were teens
too,
is I want to be a translator for you of
some of what I would say are the more
toxic messages about success
that girls are getting. Um,
because I think it's very important that
we as advocates for girls, as educators,
as teachers, as parents, that we learn how
to talk back to some of those messages,
um, so that we can shield them
from those messages. And finally,
what are the skills that you both need?
Meaning you,
both parent and girl need,
um,
to help her redefine success
in some healthy ways.
So let's start off with a couple of
changes that have occurred since I was
younger, although I kind of want to
start with even an earlier change.
Um, and meaning something
that's been around for a long
time and I'm going to ask
the members of the audience
to do a brief exercise.
I promise there won't be
anything else after this.
You can be totally just hanging out,
but if you could sit,
as you would imagine a typical guy
sits in his chair, like how do you,
okay, so everybody, for those be
livestreaming, everybody's like,
man spreading right now.
Everyone's like spread now.
And then how do you think a
typical girl sits in her chair?
There's no more laughing. Just if you
can't hear the typical girl posture,
everyone is starting to contract.
Everyone's sitting up
street crossing their legs,
looking like they're being watched.
And Yeah,
you guys were totally manspreading
during the, during the man thing.
And I love that activity because I think
it illustrates what people would call
gender norms,
some of the unwritten rules that girls
and guys grow up with about how you're
supposed to act.
And what I also liked about that activity,
and it's a great one to
do with your own family,
is it allows us to think not just about
the space that guys might be given to
take up with their bodies,
but also with their voices and
their opinions and their appetites.
Because when I asked you to sit like a
girl, everyone suddenly gets smaller.
And so there are often also messages
that girls get about the permission they
should be taking up or not taking up the
space that they should be taking up or
not taking up with their voices and their
opinions. Um, and why does this matter?
Well,
it matters because in addition to this
pressure that girls get not to take up
too much space, we have also
said two girls, hey, guess what?
You can go do and be anything.
So we've said to girls like,
would you like to go now be an engineer?
Fantastic.
Would you like to go work at Google and
study cognitive science and you know,
do robotics? Absolutely. Awesome.
What we haven't done is
we haven't said to them,
but you don't have to worry
about being liked anymore.
You don't have to worry about
pleasing others anymore.
You don't have to worry about having
that perfect bikini body anymore.
What psychologists call, what girls
are facing right now is role overload,
which basically means too many
roles for one person to play.
Role overload is linked to a lot
of stress. As you can imagine. Um,
you may be surprised or not to learn
that adolescent girls get the least sleep
of any group of youth.
And I honestly think that this is in
part due to the expectation that you not
just be smart, but you also better get
one like permitted on Instagram. Um,
God help you if you don't. You also
need to be involved in activities.
You need to be in charge of
the captain of a team. Um,
and that is fatiguing.
It leads to early burnout and it also
creates what researchers call role
conflict. So, in other
words, in a 24 hour a day,
like what it takes to have
the bikini body that you want.
I keep saying bikini body because
if you open up Instagram, um,
and you even this week,
there's a lot of young people on spring
break and I actually follow a lot of
them and luckily they usually forget that
I'm following them. So I get to learn.
Um, but there's a ton of bikini
pictures coming out, right?
And it's all about look
at me and look at my body.
And it's a very specific kind
of body that's being shown off.
And what we're finding actually in the
research is that whereas it used to be
that like when I was, you know, a
hundred years ago, a teenager, um,
and I wanted to look at
somebody cute little body,
I would have to go to the grocery store,
I'd have to buy a magazine,
I'd have to look at a celebrity.
What's different for girls?
Is it all you have to
do is open your phone.
And not only are you going to
see the bodies of celebrities,
but you're also going to see,
um,
the bodies of your friends and that can
create and that is creating body shame
that is creating, um, concern and a
loss of confidence in their own body.
So these are some of the things
that are really different. Um,
another thing that I would call as
different as what I like to affectionately
call the college application
industrial complex. Um,
and by that I mean the very
intense pressure that girls
face almost from middle
school at this point that the,
this sort of message,
they get that if they don't craft
themselves into the most perfect specimen
worthy of college admission,
they are going to lead mediocre lives.
They really get this pressure that
they have to be absolutely amazing at
everything they do. And if they don't, um,
I dunno like cure major disease and
their science project in middle school,
like they're going to
lead very unhappy lives.
And what they feel is that there are
whole worthiness is kind of riding on that
day. Whether or not they get accepted
into the college of their choice.
And I think what it's doing
is it's sending them some
very toxic about success.
Um, one of them is the expectation that
they'd be amazing at everything that they
do. What can you say to girls and
frankly to ourselves about this,
this expectation? I mean, first of all,
there's absolutely no way that we can
be amazing at everything we do. No Way.
And in fact, if you expect
yourself always, I mean,
at what I do with girls and I sort of say,
if you always expect
yourself to be up here,
you are invariably going to
feel that you are not enough.
You will feel that you are less
then you will feel that you, um,
in the moment as you are or not worthy.
And it is impossible to try to be amazing
at everything you do. And when you try,
in addition to feeling
that self criticism,
the other thing that happens is that you
feel like you can't take any risks. And,
um, you know, as I speak at a place like
Google, I feel like Google is all about,
you know, taking risks, asking
questions, being curious.
And if you feel that you have to play it
safe because you can't mess up because
you've got to get that perfect resume,
you've got to have that perfect GPA,
your muscle for risk,
taking,
your ability to comfortably face
uncertainty, that will atrophy.
And I think what we want for our girls,
if you really want to be brave,
you have to regularly put
yourself out there in small ways.
I never say I, I'm not a big believer
in the um, Eleanor Roosevelt saying, uh,
do something everyday that scares
you because I'm kind of like,
who wants to be scared every day?
Do you guys want to be scared every day?
I'm not down with that personally.
No.
I would like to be like a little
nervous every day. I could do that.
I could get with that.
Um,
that was my long winded way of saying
that comfort with risk taking happens
through small things that we do all
the time to challenge ourselves.
When girls are trying to be perfect,
they lose comfort with risk taking
and it diminishes their courage.
The other thing that happens is what
I affectionately call the mass mass
nationwide adolescent hallucination that
all my friends are doing and being more
than I am. I'm, in other words, girls
are often taken with the sense that like,
obviously all my friends
are smarter than me.
All my friends are doing more than me.
Um,
they're cooler than I am and I think it's
super important to talk to girls about
the kind of futility of that attitude
because the reason why you think
everyone's doing more than you
is because you don't feel enough.
If you're trying to get up
here all the time, of course,
you're looking over your shoulder
being like, who's coming up behind me?
One of the most common questions I've
been asked on the road for this tour has
come from girls who come
to my talk and they say,
what am I supposed to do about the fact
that I don't feel happy for my friends
when they succeed? What do I do about
the fact that like there's something,
there's a competition between me and my
friends where I don't feel like I don't
feel good about it and we're not talking
about it and it's eating away at our
relationship.
Now I think this is a warning sign
in terms of when we think about women
supporting other women,
if girls are operating from a belief
that even their friends are potentially
threats to their own success,
again,
stemming from that sense
that they are not enough,
what does that mean for how women
support each other later on? So, um,
there are quite a few. Um, I
wouldn't call them side effects,
but there are real consequences to what's
happening around the culture in terms
of that pressure to be admitted to a
four year college or university. Um,
so what are some things you can say
to the girl in your life who might be
struggling?
I have been totally blown away by how
much the following makes a difference to a
teenager's wellbeing saying to them,
I don't think this is your fault,
what you're going through. In
other words, a lot of teenagers,
girls and guys who are overwhelmed
by anxiety and stress, they very, um,
they're very convinced that like,
what's wrong with me?
That I can't overcome this?
What's wrong with me?
That I can't keep up and to say
to a teenager, you know what,
what's wrong has very little to do with
you and much more to do with how broken
this culture is around achievement and
success and the pressures that it's
putting on you. It's very, it's
transformative for a teenager because,
and I don't want to oversimplify my work,
but I do believe that when you can make
a teenager feel like they're not the
only one suffering from something.
And I mean I think we all can feel
the benefits of that awareness.
But when you can tell her this isn't
just you, it makes a huge difference.
The other thing I think we need to say
is we don't want to tell them why are you
guys putting so much
pressure on yourselves?
I know I was told that many years ago
by my parents and I actually wrote an
article in the Washington Post about a
month ago about this very thing and in it
I really call on parents to stop telling
their kids that they put too much
pressure on themselves. And here's
why. When you say that to a kid,
the implication is if you could just
chill, everything would be fine.
Cause it's just like all you,
that you're,
you're just doing this to
yourself when in fact we know,
and hopefully I've convinced you somewhat,
but this is a cultural issue.
This is something much bigger than
what one kid is doing to herself.
And it's actually much more helpful
to your kid to hear that everybody's
struggling right now. And you could
have a really peaceful home. Like,
let me be clear,
you could have an amazing house that is
like super then and like very spa like,
and you really aren't putting pressure
on your kid and I totally believe you
that you're not. However, the second
year kid walks out of your house,
she is flooded with that stress. So it's
not about what she's doing to herself.
I want to talk about
imposter syndrome right now.
This is a picture of Maya Angelo and who
is obviously a giant of a human being,
um, and and a writer and
a poet and so many things.
She has been very public about her
struggle with imposter syndrome and she
believes and has said that,
you know,
she has this abiding fear that at some
point she's going to be found out and
when she's found out,
you know,
everyone's gonna see that she's not
nearly as smart or as talented as everyone
thinks.
Well,
one of the great surprises of my research
with girls has been the extent to
which imposter syndrome is with
them from a very early age. In fact,
I discovered research that said that
it's firmly in place by adolescence.
And I asked my students,
I work on a college campus and I asked
my students all the time to finish the
sentence.
Uh,
I say sometimes I worry that I'm not
as blank as other people think I am.
Um, and I've also started doing the same
with adults. The most common response,
the most common fill in the blank is
I worry that I'm not as smart as other
people think I am. So what do we
say to our kids and to ourselves?
Because my goodness, I also struggle
with imposter syndrome for sure. Um,
and um, and relatively frequently
I was going to joke between meals,
but not that frequently,
but a lot. Um, you know,
when that voice comes up inside of us,
when we hear that voice that says,
you don't deserve to be here, you don't
belong here, you don't have what it takes.
We have to talk back to it.
And we do this in two ways.
One is we realize that this
voice is a voice inside of us,
but it's not the voice that
is us, right? It's not you.
It's the small scared part of
you that kind of rears its head.
But it does not mean that it is used.
So we really need to teach not
only our kids but ourselves,
that that's a recurring part of us,
but we don't over identify with it.
And the second thing you do is you
name it. And I've actually had,
I had one student who named
her imposter voice Leicester,
which I thought was hilarious. And so
she'd be like, Yo, less drag off this.
You step off. Okay,
like Lester, I hear you.
I hear you telling me that I'm not smart
enough to be in this AP class or I'm
not. Whatever it is, enough
chill, dude. Just have a seat.
And so when you talk back
to and you name that voice,
it actually gives you an ability
to separate yourself from it. Um,
gratitude is a very powerful
practice that research tells us,
does everything from help us
sleep better at night, um,
boost our immune systems.
And elevator wellness.
And basically what this sounds like is
a kind of simple acknowledgement which
you can do any time of what it is
you are grateful for right now.
It does not have to be epic or
polished or important beyond.
I'm happy the sun came out
like I, you know what I'm
grateful for today. Honestly,
I was staying in Mill Valley last night
because I spoke there for my book.
I woke up,
I didn't have time to go to the gym,
which was five minutes away and there
was a terrible storm here last night.
And um, and somehow it stopped
raining and I got to go run outside.
And a few minutes after I came back in,
it started pouring and I
just took a moment and said,
I'm so grateful that I got to get
my heart rate up. That's enough.
That's enough when we
can in small moments,
say this thing that happened,
that's enough for me.
It allows us to be on the
ground instead of going up here.
It allows us to affirm
what matters right now,
but we also have to be willing to buy
into the fact that the small things count.
And I think a gradual practice,
and I want to say practice cause it's
just like that muscle that we have to flex
for risk taking is just like the do
something that makes me nervous every day.
We're not talking about
becoming like a zen monk.
We're talking about you're driving to
work. Uh, what are you grateful for?
Just stop and think about it. And this
can open up something inside of you,
a place of appreciation that can make
you feel enough in this very moment right
now. And I, it's been very powerful
for me and my young daughter as well.
Well I hope it's so powerful for her.
I might just be hallucinating,
but I think it's, I'm
hoping that it is. Um,
there are a couple of things that I want
to cover in this talk beyond some of
the smaller pieces of advice that I've
given you that are in the research, um,
considered very palliative
factors in adolescent wellness.
One of them is purpose. So
what's purpose, purpose,
having a sense of purpose in your life
means that you do something that you're
into. You really like doing
this, pursuing this goal,
but this particular goal or this thing
that you're involved in connects you to
something bigger than you. All right?
It's not like a self oriented goal.
So let's just think of
something purposeful. Um,
something that makes an impact
on the world in some way.
I mean it could be volunteering,
it could also be creating an APP.
It doesn't mean that it has
to be public service oriented.
I was on a public radio show
in the bay area yesterday,
a call or phoned in and talked about
how his daughter who had been riven with
anxiety discovered juggling.
And once she discovered juggling,
she began traveling and juggling for
underserved children and that this healed
her. And that's a sense of purpose. She
was part of something bigger than herself.
Contrast that with the kid who says,
my goal is to get good grades.
My goal is to be accepted
into a brand name college.
My goal is to score
perfect score on the sat.
People who are driven by self
oriented goals tend to be less happy.
They also tend to be less resilient.
Um,
I'll tell you who else actually just to,
I want to deviate from this purpose or,
or digress from this purpose conversation
for just a moment to say that there's
another,
there are two other differences that I
want to talk with you about in terms of
types of goals you pursue.
So Carol Dweck who is a psychologist
based at Stanford University who studies
motivation talks about the difference
between pursuing a performance goal and a
learning goal.
Now,
a performance goal is when you undertake
something at the approval that you
might get from others or because
you wish to avoid failure.
A learning goal,
which spoiler alert is what we want
girls to have and what we should all be
trying to pursue.
Um,
more than anything is when you undertake
a goal because you're trying to master
something,
you want to undertake this thing because
you really want to learn about it.
So for example, I want to master the
French, uh, the past tense in French.
That's a learning goal. I want to get
an a in French is a performance goal.
Now there's nothing wrong with
performance goals on their face,
like it's totally fine to want to be,
I'm just strive for attention and reward,
but that can't be the primary
thing that drives you.
Definitely not because for those
people who are driven per primarily by
performance goals, they are also less
resilient. They are also more unhappy.
Now, why are you, why are you less tough?
If you're driven by a performance goal,
we'll think about it. If what is
driving you isn't coming from within,
isn't inspired by a kind of genuine desire
that comes intrinsically from within
you,
it's so much easier to knock you over
so you have a setback and because you're
more invested in what other people think,
it's so much easier to get knocked over
because you don't have the grounding in
your own desire and in
your own motivation.
So what that means for you as parents
or for yourself as you pursue your own
goals is to say,
Hey,
am I doing this because I want to
or because I feel like I have to?
Are you taking that class?
You could say to your kid because you,
you really want to learn this thing.
Are you doing it because you
think it looks good? And again,
nothing wrong with wanting to look good,
but that can't be the primary
reason why purposeful.
A purposeful life is on the decline.
In terms of goals of adolescents.
Adolescents are increasingly saying, I
want to make money. I want to, you know,
get a great job.
I wanted to go to a good college.
The percentage of students who say,
I want to lead a meaningful life
has experienced a steep decline.
And researchers believe this is absolutely
related to the decline in wellness in
teenagers when you are with your
daughter and if your daughter or you,
um, honestly, because I'm,
what I'm about to say absolutely comes
to my own mind as I stand in the face of
a risk.
But if you want to get your kid to do
something that's challenging to her,
if you yourself want to take a leap,
there are three questions
that work really well.
One is what do you think the
worst that could happen is?
And I want to clarify here,
girls are particularly good at telling
you the absolute worst thing that could
happen on a catastrophic level.
And so I want to just sort of amend this
by saying like actual worst that could
happen. Not like catastrophe worst
that can happen. Um, you know,
because girls are such
good catastrophizers and
then can you live with it?
So for example,
um,
and I say this too because I know a lot
of girls who don't want to take risks,
they don't want to raise their hands
unless they have the right answer.
They don't want to try out for the play
because they're afraid they will get
apart.
They have like application fee or I don't
want to apply for that job because I'm
afraid I won't get it or that
internship or that fellowship. Um,
and so we say to them,
what is the worst that can happen
and can you live with that?
It's very rare that I have a student
who says, no, I can't live with that.
Most people once they really are
willing to look the consequence,
not the catastrophe consequence, the legit
one in the eye. They were like, yeah,
I could live with that.
Another question that has been profoundly
helpful for me personally is as you
stand in the face of a challenge,
a risk,
you're going to put yourself out there
in some way. You say to yourself,
what is the minimum benefit that
I could get from this thing?
Like what's the least good thing that
could come out of this experience and I
feel extremely strongly
about what I'm about to say.
If you want yourself or if you want
your daughter to resist perfectionism,
we have to help them appreciate
the beauty of the process.
We have to help them appreciate that
there are always unanticipated benefits,
lessons,
moments of inspiration and wisdom
that come when we least expect it.
That come when the big moment of glory
doesn't arrive so that even if you don't
get into that play or you get a
crappy chorus part and like, wow,
that's a bummer and I'm sorry.
There are other benefits that come from
this experience. You make new friends,
you learn a new skill,
you learn that you can stick stuff out.
That's not what you
thought it was going to be.
I think that when we all
imagine like what are like,
if you think to yourself what
in the face of an obstacle,
have I learned what from a
heartbreak have I gained?
We ask ourselves this question as adults,
the same kind of a wisdom
will accrue to our children.
We have to have faith that it will.
I think as parents you don't
want them to be suffering, right?
We don't want our children to be in
anguish in any way and yet the same wisdom
and strength and courage that we have
gained from our own obstacles will also
come in due time to our children and we
have to have patients with that create
space for that because ultimately if
all we are driven by is the big polished
finish is the outcome is the
college essay worthy moment.
Then of course our children
will be addicted to perfection.
I want to talk to more things.
I want to say before I hand it over to
Samone marine from girls leadership.
Um,
parents need to practice
what psychologists call self
regulation just as much as
our kids do, right? Just as much as we
expect our kids to keep it together.
We also as parents have to do that.
Um,
and that's because it's really hard to
watch our teenagers go through the ups
and downs, the chaos of this time. So
here are three things you can do. One,
remember she is still watching you.
I say this because teenagers
are exceptionally good at
acting like they do not
care at best what you say and think
you're clueless and stupid at worst. Um,
and it's very important to remember that
even if you think your child doesn't
want to connect with you anymore,
it's not that it's the way she wants to
connect with you as deeply unsatisfying,
often,
often as the case.
I'm just going to be assuming
that everyone here is
laughing on the inside about
that one. Um, but anyway,
um, I still think it's funny,
so thank you for laughing.
Anyway, my point is that, um, your kid,
your teenagers absolutely still
connected to you. They are still,
they still want to know what you think
and the way that you react as a parent in
the face of a problem. Um, they
are absolutely downloading that.
They are mimicking it too in the sense
that just like they used to mimic the
words you say when,
when they were little,
they're now starting to mimic
how do you respond to distress?
How do you respond when things don't
go your way? They are watching us. Um,
and we do have to be careful with
how much anxiety we bring into our
conversations with them. Number
two, share your mistakes.
Do not imagine that being a good role
model to your kid is about acting like
you've never do anything
wrong when you do that.
When you don't tell them
about your setbacks,
they think that it's not okay for them
to experience them themselves and worse
or maybe related. They become afraid
to tell you about their own mistakes.
Number three,
ask yourself this question and this is a
shout out to Sheryl Sandberg's question
and lean in when she posed the question,
what would you do if you weren't afraid?
When you stand in the face of
deep anxiety around your child,
when you look at something
that's not going well and
you say this thing happened,
what if this means blank? Because I think
parents can also catastrophize, right?
We can also say something went wrong here.
What if this means globally that
she's not going to make friends?
What if this means she's not that smart?
What if this means she doesn't
go to a good college? As parents,
we have to check ourselves.
We've got to walk that back down away
from the global anxiety down to what's
really happening and one of the best
ways to do that is to ask yourself,
all right, if I knew that everything
was going to be okay, right?
If I knew that would ever is freaking me
out right now about my kid was going to
be fine, if I could practice faith
and optimism, if I were not afraid,
how would you parent?
If you are not afraid,
the choices that we make in that moment
when we're not afraid are so much wiser.
They are choices were much
more likely to be proud of.
Then when we make choices from a place
of fear and what if and what does this
mean an anxiety.
The last thing I want to introduce
you to is self compassion.
Self compassion is a second,
um,
strongly research-based
palliative factor for adolescents.
It is the practice of being gentle with
yourself in the face of a challenge. Now,
many people think that gentleness with
yourself in the face of a challenge is
not only a way of being
lazy about your problems,
but also could result in complete
paralysis because who would possibly be
motivated if they weren't being
mean to themselves? This is,
these are all common responses to self
compassion responses I should say.
Like I had myself for sure when
I first encountered it. In fact,
what self compassion is about is not
pretending that something didn't happen or
taking responsibility. It's basically
about saying, yeah, something happened.
I don't feel good about it,
but I'm not going to trade away myself.
Worth in the process of
dealing with it include,
I also want to add that that research
shows that self compassion does not
diminish motivation and it doesn't
diminish performance standards.
So here's what it is. Here's
what, here's how it works.
There are three steps that
were developed by, um,
University of Texas at Austin Professor
Kristin Neff who has a book of the same
name, self compassion, a wonderful
website of course a tedtalk. And um,
the three steps work this way and I'm
going to teach them by telling the Google
world about something that happened to
me and how I learned to practice self
compassion. So, um, the first
step is mindfulness. Now,
several years ago I was really royally
and radically dumped and I went into a
total tailspin about what this
meant about me. So I, I'm,
I'm also an excellent
catastrophizer recovering now.
And so I went into this place of obviously
like I'm a broken human being who's
going to die alone with dogs,
not cats because I'm allergic to cats,
but I think you got my reference.
And like clearly nothing good will
ever happen to me again in my life.
So that's not mindful, right?
Mindful is not catastrophizing.
Mindfulness means all right,
something bad happened.
What do I really feel right now?
Like what? What is my actual emotion?
Not The denial or the
catastrophe. I feel sad, right?
Like I'm grieving and the next,
well this week,
I mean probably the next year is
going to be really hard for me.
The second step of self
compassion is self kindness.
This is hard for a lot of people.
Deceptively simple and this basically
means like if you had a really close
friend who you loved,
who is being mean to themselves and the
way that you were being mean to you,
what would you say to your friend?
Because the reality is aren't we
so much nicer to other people?
We show other people so much more
grace than we show ourselves.
So this is a thing.
I also do this by the way,
by channeling one of my best friends who
I call my unicorn friend because she's
like so much nicer. It's sometimes
I think than I am. I'm like,
why are you friends with me?
Because you're so nice. And like,
do you ever have a friend like that?
I call her my unicorn friend.
Trudy actually knows her.
And um,
and I imagine what my friend Daniella
would say to me cause she's so nice and I
think what would Danielle is say, I got
to say that to myself. And then the, um,
the third step of self compassion,
another really powerful step is common
humanity. And what that means is,
are there other people who might
be suffering the way I'm suffering?
Like am I the only one
who's ever been dumped?
Thank you Google for telling me that
heartbreak advice gets 1.5 million hits.
Google was instrumental in helping
me understand that I was not alone.
So thank you Google. Seriously,
I promise you I did this.
And when you know you're not alone,
it is so helpful the,
the feeling of aloneness and isolation
that so many of us have exacerbates shame.
It makes us not want to solve a problem.
And so reminding ourselves,
we do have a shared
experience of suffering.
We are not by ourselves
is absolutely powerful.
So following these three steps,
I strongly encourage you to practice this.
You can do it in the middle of the night.
If you ever wake up,
you had an extra glass of red wine,
you woke up at two in the morning.
I'm not saying I've experienced
that personally, of course
I have. And um, yeah,
and you walk yourself
through these three steps.
You Walk Yourself and you practice
just like you practice risk taking,
just like you practice gratitude.
The bottom line is that we all have to
be able to access why we are enough as we
are. And one of the best ways
to do that is to ask yourself,
what about me is valuable and of worth
beyond my external standards of success
beyond my salary,
beyond my position,
beyond the accomplishments that I may
want to share or that I think define me?
What beyond those standards
makes me enough as I am.
And when you know that you can be stronger
than you've ever thought possible.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
So I'd like to turn over the mic to
Simone Marine and my dear friend,
my colleague,
um,
who is fiercely committed to
making sure that every girl,
no matter what her income
level or background,
has the power and the skills to
exercise the power of her voice.
So I want to introduce everyone to Simone,
the CEO and cofounder of girls
leadership. Thank you, Rachel.
Okay.
I mission at girls' leadership is to equip
girls with the skills to exercise the
power of their voice.
And we see this as the
foundational skill of leadership,
no matter what a girl wants to pursue,
whether it is coding or business or arts
or government and all the places where
we want our girls to have leadership.
And I would like to say, um,
before telling you
briefly about who we are,
that I am so grateful to be back at
Google and grateful for the support of a
Googler, his contributions and,
uh, the matching program here,
which has made such a powerful difference.
Um,
and our work every year
at girls' leadership,
particularly in our ability to serve girls
in schools, in low income communities.
So thank you for that support.
Um,
what makes girls leadership unique
and the girl serving spaces?
Really three things.
One is that we are the only organization
to partner with the adults' and girls'
lives.
What we have found is that when we teach
a girl the skills to exercise the power
of her voice,
but she goes back to a school or to a
family that doesn't support that and
doesn't understand her voice,
that what we teach can be undone.
But if we work with the girl, not only
the girl, but also her, her teacher,
the caregiver,
the anti,
the Nana in her life who's giving
her scripts every day and giving her
permission, that's true.
Sustainable change. Um,
so of the 10,000 people that
we teach in person every year,
over 5,000 of those are the
adults and girls lives. Um,
the second thing that makes us unique
is that we are really grounded and
emotional intelligence,
which I think is so much of the work
that Rachel has been talking about.
This social emotional learning, these
invisible skills and processing. Um,
that is as is the vital foundation of
the external skills that we want them to
demonstrate, uh, in academics
or in the workplace.
And so our belief is that if a girl knows
what she thinks and feels and needs,
if she respects it,
that's the hard part that many of us
lose over the course of adolescence.
And she has the ability to express
it affectively. Those three things,
we'll provide that foundation for her.
The last piece that really makes us
powerful is that we see girls everyday
relationships as her
incubator for leadership. The,
so rather than saying to the girls,
if you are chosen as captain of the team,
if you are present to the class,
then you are a leader and
you have influenced where
are instead saying to girls,
uh,
leadership is a way of life.
You get to decide and the countless
decisions that you make every day, uh,
whether you're going to have influence
when you decide whether you, how you look,
somebody in the eye,
do you raise your hand in class
when you don't know the answer?
Do you raise your hand in class?
When you do know the answer,
where do you sit at lunch? Um, high
school or recently reminded me,
do you eat lunch? Uh,
was a leadership, uh,
question that she had to face everyday.
Where do you sit at lunch?
All of these countless
decisions are opportunities
that girls have to build this
self awareness and agency and
ability to make change. Um,
so those three things,
emotional intelligence is the foundation.
Adults are our partners and everyday
relationships are the incubator or what
makes girls leadership who we are.
Uh,
and right now we're focused
on to strategic initiatives.
One is that we are looking deeply at the
experience of girls and women of color
and really trying to
understand how does race,
ethnicity and income level
impact gender expectations.
Because what we're finding is
there's very different, uh,
experiences that girls
have in different cultures.
And if we can gather the
data on that difference,
then we'll be able to reach the 25 million
girls in the US where they are across
those infinite differences that exist.
So that's the first
thing that we're doing.
And then we're also very much focused
on a educator training as the vehicle to
scaling our curriculum.
That uh,
reaching each girl one
by one is a slow process.
But if we can reach the educators,
the administrators, the principals,
the people that have power over
hundreds if not of girls lives,
that's um,
how we can really move the dial quickly
in the u s and so the last thing I would
like to say is we have a
couple Googlers on our board,
but if anyone would like to be
involved and participate in this work,
we are very grateful for the partnership
and the support of many is like
treating Mckenna has been here
over the years for myself. Um,
so please reach out to me if you're
interested in being involved. Thank you.
Great.
Thank you. Okay, let's go to Q and.
A. If you have a question in the room,
go ahead and head to the mic and we will
be watching the dory for anybody who
has questions. Again, it's a go slash
Rachel Simmons Dash Story and Oh great.
We have a question in the room.
Let's start with that. Thank you.
Thank you very much. And
small. Uh, my question might
be the, I'm either, I'll be,
you can ask are probably,
um, my question is about,
so I observe this tendency among,
so I have a radio world calling myself
and I was there with this tendency for
her to very quickly identify her BFF,
our school and sort of a constraint,
her relationship with this just small
number of friends. So even have to,
she is sitting next to a
mother, a daughter. You're a
god that she just met today.
If he was a boy then I think they,
there's more tendency for them to kind
of play a wrong as long as this kid is
well behaving. But, um, my
goal wouldn't talk. So I,
I'm not sure if this is good or bad.
Like Carolyn more about
relationship is good,
but I'm not expanding it is bad.
So I'm not sure how they sort
of come out in our future.
So I wanted to get your thoughts.
I think this is a [inaudible] question.
Yes, I would you want to come up here
and um, we'll do a little duet on that.
Songs. I don't have to sing. They
sing islands in the stream now. Yeah.
I mean there's an incredible pressure
on girls to find that BFF and not,
and to find her on the first day of
kindergarten and it's an eye contact and
there's rainbows and glitter. Right?
My little ponies. Yes. Jump around. Um,
and,
and I think we do need,
and the cost of that is like the BFF
rules are basically you like all the same
things. You do everything together and you
never fight. Right? Any of us as adults,
if we can imagine a 24 hour relationship
where we like all the same things,
we do everything together
and we never fight, right?
This myth is the biggest setup of all
time because of course all those things
are gonna happen.
So I think it is important
that we dismantled that
myth for girls and we really
teach them what healthy relationships
look like and that how to navigate
disagreements and how to make people
feel included. And it, it is, I have my,
I have a six year old son and it's
still every day teach, you know,
giving him scripts.
And,
and teaching him about the impact
of his relationship choices.
And so when he doesn't talk to
that person next to him, right,
how does that make them feel? And what
is, you know, and I call it leadership,
like when you're,
when you have influenced them,
when you reach out to somebody
and when you're inclusive,
what's that change that you're making
in the world and that they can take on
that bigger label and that
bigger meaning of their actions.
So it is important to look at that
myth and that gender expectation,
dismantle it,
and help her build the full set of skills
to connect with people across a range
of differences. Couldn't have said it
better myself. So I hope that was helpful.
Yeah. And we do have several
questions on the dory. So,
all right,
so our top question right now on the
door is from Hillary and she asks,
how can parents lay the groundwork
for these skills and younger children?
I'm so happy you asked
that Hilary, because, uh,
I'm also the parent of a younger child
and you may know the common phrase,
little kids, little problems,
big kids, big problems.
And so by that I take from that
that little kids are somewhat more
impressionable on, easier, a
little bit easier to work with.
So what are some things you
can do with a young child? Um,
one you can make the practice of
gratitude part of every breakfast.
So every day at breakfast,
what is one thing you're grateful for
and you say it and they say it. Um,
again,
one of the benefits of doing this with
younger children is that as they proceed
into the eye rolling years,
they at least have this laid,
this groundwork that's been laid, um,
which helps keep them much more connected.
You have a much better
chance of hanging on. Um,
another thing you can do is talk
with them about the way they talk to
themselves.
So if you,
if you're physically comfortable going
to a place where you could maybe jump
over something with your child,
like for example like bouldering,
climbing on rocks or walking by a creek
and stepping on the rocks in the creek
and you since your daughter
anxious about something,
and I'm using the creek is an example,
but there are all kinds of things we
might do with our child where she feels
afraid when she's young.
You say to her,
it's a good thing to talk to yourself
in a positive way to say, I can do this,
I can do this. Teach her what
internal self talk sounds like.
This is certainly something my daughter
has has absolutely internalized and who
is almost six years old and
who does this frequently. Um,
another great thing to do is when your
daughter is working on something that's
challenging for her and you can feel
her starting to either get frustrated or
want to walk away from it. You go up and
you give her tons of praise and you say,
look how far you've gotten at this.
Look how much you've done already.
And that's known as
process praise process.
Praise is about making sure kids feel
really good about being in the middle of a
challenging process,
making sure they feel praised for
sticking with it and being a part of it as
opposed to waiting until they finished
and cross the finish line as it were,
to give them the praise.
We know from research that,
and I find this amazing that they've
been able to figure this out.
We'll come to coming
out of Stanford that um,
even in toddlerhood boys get
more processed praise than girls,
which is unbelievable to me. And
if you hear process praise, if you,
if you are praised for like,
another way to ask this is, um,
let's say your kid is working
on something and you say,
tell me about the strategy that you used.
And by the way,
teach them the word strategy because
strategy implies there's always more than
one solution. There's lots of
different ways to do something.
So what kind of strategy did you use to,
to figure that out and they can get
excited about what they've done so far.
So all of this helps make kids braver
because it means they don't have to
perform at the highest level.
It means they know you care when they're
in it and in the process and trying.
So those are all things that you can do.
There's,
there's so much to do with younger girls.
So first I want to say I'm currently
reading enough as she is and one of the
struggles I'm having is reading
it as both being an ass out,
like still being,
growing up and kind of trying to view it
from maybe how my mother felt about me
growing up.
Um,
and something that my mother and I've
been talking about and trying to work out
for a long time is the fact
that it doesn't so much.
It didn't so much matter to me what
she said in matter to me, what she did.
And I would just near her behaviors,
even if she was telling me the opposite.
And as somebody who struggles
with things in my own life,
I wonder if you have any advice on
if you know you have a problem and,
and you participate in a behavior that
would be very damaging to mimic and yet
you're still struggling yourself to not
do it. How do you communicate this with,
uh, with somebody who might be
watching you as a role model? Um,
that's a great question.
So meaning you have awareness of the
behavior that someone is mimicking. Well,
of course the pat answer is do
as I say, but not as I do. Um,
but I think you're pointing to
something deeper, which is, um,
and something that's been
studied actually, it's just
beginning to be studied,
which is the way that young people can
tell the difference between what their
parents values are and what their
parents actually say. So in other words,
teens have a great bs detector. They
know that their parent might say, Oh,
I really want you to be happy.
And they at the same time
know their parent is very
committed to them getting to
it into the best possible college
which may actually contraindicate their
happiness. And so, um,
so I think that you're,
you're really highlighting something
that's quite, quite new in the,
in the research.
But of course your question is about how
do you relate to somebody when you know
that you're mimicking, that
you're modeling something,
um, that's not healthy.
And I guess I think the kind of,
um,
I know Bernay Brown was here at Google
yesterday. I think vulnerability,
authentic vulnerability is really
important. So to be able to say, Oh,
I'm most as part admission
of what's going on,
but also part apology if
you believe it's called for.
I know on a smaller scale that in the
moments where I let my own child down,
when I fail my own child,
whether it's because I have yelled in a
way that wasn't appropriate or it for,
or I have been too dismissive or
distracted, I catch myself and I say,
I'm really sorry for what I just did. And
just like, it's okay. It's okay. Like,
I think she gets like, mom, stop being
awkward cause we live in New England and
she apparently has no feelings. This is a
we've anyway, um, she's like, please stop,
please stop. And she's only six. But I
say, I try to say to her, you know, this,
this wasn't right and I need to
make right. I need to make it right.
I need to make it better. I
don't beat myself up. But I,
so it's a combination of
that vulnerability, that
authentic vulnerability, um,
but also being willing to be accountable
and to say I don't have it all
together.
And it goes back to what I said earlier
about the importance of making mistakes
in front of your kids because your kids
need to know how to screw up as much as
they need to know how to succeed.
You will not have,
you can't know how to succeed well truly
well if you don't have the tools to
make mistakes.
And yet so many of us as parents,
we err too much on the side of we're
gonna teach you how to succeed.
And that's really part of what this book
is about. Um, I'm a big fan of the book,
lean in and I believe what we need to
teach our kids to do is to lean inside so
that they have the tools to be strong
and to navigate the barriers and the
unforeseen moments that arise
when they are pursuing success.
Great. We have another question on
the dory. This one's from Elizabeth.
She says she's currently reading
the curse of the good girl.
I'm published in 2010 specifically in
regard to part to breaking the curse.
Is there anything you'd update or advice
you'd modify based on things you've
learned and observed since
it was published? Wow, that's
a really good question.
Um, well I guess yes, absolutely.
And I actually talk about this in enough
as she is, that's a wonderful question.
Yeah,
I kind of realized that I screwed up a
little bit in the curse of the good girl.
So Elizabeth,
Maya Culpa,
and if you decide that you like my
work enough to read the next one, um,
you'll see actually talking about this.
So in the curse of the good girl,
I argue that the most important thing
girls need in order to thrive is to break
that curse is to not have to
sit like a girl all the time,
is to be able to speak up and you know,
not feel like they have to be modest
and have conflicts and express their
feelings.
And I thought that if girls could do that,
they would lead happier,
healthier lives. But why,
where I've,
so here's the problem with that is that
I was putting way too much emphasis on
the role of the girl.
I was not at all thinking about how
toxic the culture is for the girl.
And I think that just stems from my own
like can do I come from a very immigrant
family. Like you can do
it. Like just bootstrap it,
figure it out kind of
mentality that I grew up with.
That actually it wasn't fair to girls.
The thing that I've realized now almost
10 years later is that the data that we
see,
um,
around the world really in terms of
what girls are facing around anxiety and
depression and stress.
And the percentage of girls who say
on college campuses at the age of 18,
that I feel overwhelmed
by all I have to do.
These are all stratospherically rising.
That's not about the girls failure.
That's about the way we are
failing girls. And so, um,
and I do think becoming a parent
changed things for me. Um, it, it,
it allowed me to see the things that I
could control and the things that I can't
and then we all need to
work together to change.
All right. Another question
from the dory from Sri Lanka.
I apologize if I butchered
your name. Um, she asks,
teaching kids to be independent versus
being there through the process example,
would you sit with them
passively or actively,
passively or actively through a homework
or leave them to work it out if, if and,
and let them ask if they have a question?
Such a great question.
And I think as our kids get older,
that is the kind of million dollar
question is where is the balance between
finding that zone of struggle and growth
that doesn't push them over the edge
and make them deteriorate into a tantrum
or whatever. Um, I think that is an art.
It's not a science. Um, I
think that what we want,
well let me tell you
what we want to avoid.
We want to avoid parenting and teaching
girls who feel like they have to ask
every five minutes. Is this right?
Is this right? Did I get it right?
I don't know if this is right.
And then what happens is they go to their
teachers and every couple minutes they
keep asking,
is this exactly what you want?
Teachers are now complaining about this
to me all over the country and it's
called learned helplessness
basically that, that, so it
is support seeking, right?
It looks like support seeking,
but it really what it is,
is it fear that if I don't get
it exactly right, oh my God,
like it's going to be a crisis. Now that
is not a muscle we want our kids to, to,
to cultivate.
And if you hear your teacher,
your daughter's teacher talk about this,
it's really important.
So how do you find that
balance? Well, first of all,
I think you have to prepare your daughter,
but beforehand and you say, listen,
I know that you're going to be doing
your homework and I want you to know that
I'm here.
And I also want you to know that my
goal is for you to challenge yourself.
And so I might not be as available to
you as I usually am because I'm going to
ask you to grapple with some stuff.
Grapple might be a big word for your kid,
but I'm going to ask you
to work on stuff yourself.
And I'm going to ask you to come up with
some strategies yourself for how you
could help yourself without necessarily
using me. So I would say to a kid,
what's one thing you could do other than
asking me? Maybe it's to call a friend.
Those are all powerful things that
they can come up with to advocate for
themselves to make good on a problem that
they have that don't involve going to
you. Then I think you have to figure out,
you have to find that growth edge, right?
I think that's the phrase.
You have to find that place with her
where she's pushing herself but not
becoming so turned off by what she's
doing that she doesn't want to do it.
Cause here's the thing.
I think when kids really start
to hate what they're doing,
I mean they hate what they're doing.
So we also have to make for that
they're not getting, um, kind of undone.
And like I said, it is an art. I wish I
had a good, hard and fast rule for that.
Actually. Wait, I have one more thing
to say. Sorry. I did think of it.
It's hard to think on your feet because
I'm like, what would I really say?
So here's what I think I
would actually say to the kid.
What is one way that you could challenge
yourself that you've never challenged
yourself before doing your homework?
That's what I would let you.
Let's come up with something that you,
that you would do to push yourself that
you haven't done before. Okay. All right.
And we've got one more question on the
dory and I think it's the last question
we'll have time for and it's
again from Hillary and she asks,
what is your take on single
gender education for girls?
Are there specific situations,
personalities where parents
should consider it?
Yes, I think so. Um,
my take on single gender education for
girls is that it can be a very important,
um, and empowering and enriching
experience for certain girls. Um,
but not necessarily for all girls.
There's a lot of great research
out there about, for example,
I'm thinking of the work of Linda Sax
at Ucla who has looked at the difference
in confidence, self reported confidence
levels, um, in the first year of college,
girls who have attended coed schools
versus single gender schools.
And there is a significant difference
that the girls who come from the all girls
school say a report, higher levels of
confidence, more speaking up in class.
That being said,
I mean I think there are wonderful
benefits to being part of a coed,
a community.
I also think,
are there certain kinds of girls that I
would recommend a single sex school too?
Yeah, I mean I think about this a lot
for my own, soon to be six year old.
And I think that if she turns out to be
a kid who is very vulnerable to social
pressure or particular round boys,
um,
who has a hard time distinguishing between
what sheet would her own values are
and what the values of her peers are.
I might seriously consider putting her
in an all girls school because I do think
that PR,
particularly around Middle School,
because I think that during that period
the powerful intense expectations to
conform to what other people are doing,
um,
can be very destructive for certain
kinds of kids who are vulnerable.
So I'm thinking a lot about that for
my own daughter and watching her. Um,
I also think that for those girls who
need more attention around things like
leadership development,
speaking up,
girls schools tend to be more oriented
to focusing on what the vulnerabilities
are that girls brings.
So I would say those two key points of
vulnerability to me would be rezoned to
seriously consider an all girls
environment. Terrific. Well, with that,
we are out of time.
Thank you so much for joining us,
thanking Rachel and Simone please.
Thank you.